we do indeed we are here with uh Brian
Owens Brian first of all welcome to the
show you uh curate the performances at
the World Chess Hall of Fame tell us a
bit your uh work there yeah so I'm one
of the music series directors and also
I'm artist resident so that's the cool
part because I get to do things like the
Fisher piece that we did in honor of the
opening ceremony and the the anniversary
of the the Fishers basket a match so
um you know just being able to really
you know Define and kind of find those
those places where chess and music line
up and meet
um they're both Universal languages to
me and so I I just I love being able to
delve more into to how they marry one
another tell us a bit about that
experience at the singfield cup how did
you come up with the idea for the song
um well
I worked with a couple people one a guy
named Adam Manis who is one of the
greatest Rangers um in this city uh Keon
Harold and um hip-hop artist Mastermind
and what we did was we got together and
I watched the Bobby Fischer documentary
and I took the different aspects of his
life and we turned those into movements
and it was really cool because
so much of the music that he loved was
well represented in the year of 1972. so
we we just kind of filled in the the
gaps of the original music that we
compose around like if there were a film
about this moment what would it sound
like and I think what it came out to be
was pretty special yeah did you get to
train any chest in preparation for that
Performance Food is full disclosure this
this is this is my chest life I barely
beat my five-year-old daughter which
would probably make my net rating about
2.5 okay so um hey that's pretty good
that's pretty good you know um so no I
mean I've I've always had an affinity
for the game of chess even though I
didn't play chess until later in into my
life but that's how I kind of view chess
it's kind of like music in a similar way
like even people who've never picked up
an instrument or who've never been
professionally
involved with the art or the craft they
understand what it is and I think that's
why you know our involvement from the
creative space moving into how it
interacts with the chess world is so
it's so sweet I mean there's so many
correlations they're both improvisatory
they both take strategy
um so I think with with those kind of
elements being being kind of parallel
and crossover it makes it makes it
really cool absolutely in fact let's
take a look at one of your performances
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
what makes the world
how can you make me a broken leg
[Music]
talk to me a bit about those moments in
front of the crowd at the World Chess
Hall of Fame how do you feel at that
point uh it's a really cool setting to
be in
um I feel like it's just big enough just
small enough it feels like an intimate
atmosphere
but you can have obviously we had you
know a full stream quartet and piano and
a band
um having people be close to the to the
the intimacy of the experience and the
music I think is a really cool cool
thing not just for me but for all the
artists who who get to perform
throughout the year uh in the series and
that's what we're really trying to go
for is really having music that fits the
the intimacy and the acoustic nature of
that space
um so I don't know man it's it's it's
been a lot of fun this is my first year
I performed on the series in years prior
but this is my first year as kind of
being the music director and curator and
it's just been a lot of fun it's been a
lot just again finding those
correlations between chess and the
creative space and there's no shortage
of them so I think like being in that
space is it's just it's an amazing
experience yeah and how can the public
interact with you guys uh do they have
tickets uh yeah I mean if you want some
schedule yeah we have we have monthly
shows you can find at the schedule by
going to the World Chess Hall of Fame
website and checking out the music
series we have a chamber music series
that Brian Woods overseas and I ever I
see I guess the non-chamber music series
um and then you know as we go along
throughout like the rest of this year
and next year we're going to get into
other experiences that we'll be
providing for the community and of
course you can check it out online
through the YouTube channel and through
the website with World Chess Hall of
Fame Brian thank you very much for uh
joining the show thank you for uh what
you're doing with the workshest Hall of
Fame great work absolutely thank you
uh Brian first of all I just got to ask
a quick question uh and a a big big
thank you I thought that your song on
the Bobby Fischer was really
extraordinary one of the most original
songs I've ever heard and I loved it I
simply just absolutely absolutely loved
it and I wanted to tell you that in 1992
I visited saf on Yugoslavia where I
spent uh time with Bobby Fisher and he
recited to me all of these lyrics of all
of these songs from Motown dude had it
down and I said well Bobby you you're
really stunning me did you ever try to
write a song he said yes sir I did I did
I I Bobby sat down for a whole week with
a with a paper and he said nothing came
out because nothing happened yeah where
do you get your inspiration
that would be the equivalent of me being
like I really love chess and I sit down
for a whole week and nothing comes out
it's the same you know and we you know
we talked about these Yasha I mean the
same way you know how do you get a chess
genius
you can be born with with the potential
for greatness but if you don't tap into
it you'll never realize it the same
amount of hours that Bobby Fischer put
into becoming a chess genius or Boris
spasky or or any number of of folks who
have been on that level
the people that you whose music you love
and appreciate they put that same amount
of time into it because it's like it's a
craft and I believe that chess is an art
and a craft yeah I have also one
question I mean um you said that you
went through many documentaries before
you wrote the song and um actually I was
wondering what impressed you the most
from what you've seen about Bobby Fisher
or what you've heard about the match
anything which kind of impressed you
so this is how do I put this
Bobby Fischer had a little gangster in
him
got from from those documentaries is
that you know Bobby Fischer had had a
little gangster in him and it's it's a
very American like like the way in which
he approached the game and approached
his brand uh was was was
quintessentially a American
um
but I but I also I also had compassion
to foresee him in those moments of
loneliness living that life being
isolated and being so locked into one
thing
um so I think you you kind of see the
blessing and the curse of it him winning
the match and his life completely
changing because he can no longer be
that isolated person
um so I don't know like I I it's like I
see the gentle gangster
Rebel with a cause Brian thank you for
all that you do and we will see you at
the World Chess Hall of Fame I love
those dinners where you share about the
many many musical artists that came from
St Louis yes I was stunned by the depth
and history of the city where music is
concerned thank you so much share some
music that's what we're doing that's
great thank you for the edumacation